[Musik]
egal
st
[Musik]
wir von der heute-show wir wollen sie
pushen wir pushen sie wir bringen sie
nach vorne wir bringen sie richtig nach
vorne nur uns ja klar
darum tragen doch die fliegen klasse
also sie auch dann neben dem navi
großzügig sind jetzt dabei was habe ich
ja keine andere wahl
sie mir vielleicht mal die anderen
kandidaten kurzen nennen ich habe mich
nur mit lauterbach beschäftigt als ihn
erkannt man mit michael roth dem matas
und saskia esken norbert walter hörmann
amick ist heute angesagt also wir sind
hier quasi in jeans hose turnschuhe die
dynamik bringen wir mit ideale sie sind
jung sie sind hipp was machen sie in spd
also wird kann man jetzt schon mal
ausschließen dass diese gruppen
das stimmt es gab ja leider auch die
eine oder andere spaß bewerbung wie
stehen sie dazu
also ich hätte mich gefreut wenn es jan
willmann geschafft hätte ich meine olaf
scholz kandidat im ganzen feld dann
klarer gerda völk das team kennen ja der
mensch haben sie eigentlich ein paar
tipps von martin schulz bekommen also ob
dieser helfer sind in der jetzigen lage
sei dahingestellt in der tat tipps tipps
haben wir bekommen ja immer das
gegenteil machen dann könnten sie
hilfreich dass so ein kommentiert adrian
tipps bekommen dass er klar ist dass
klimapolitisch nicht das völlig falsche
signal wenn total aussichtslose
kandidaten jetzt wochenlang durch die
republik reisen
ich feiere bahn also haben sie sich
angesprochen fühlt walstedde - lagen
sollte ja mal gesehen ja
bundespräsidentin werden
irgendwann ging nicht sie werden deshalb
doch sie werden
doch doch dann doch doch noch tochter
doch so einfach ist das und schon für
uns nicht haben sie waren einer fliege
und machen werbung für den richtigen
machen da irren sie sich verliebt war ja
da war ich und das ist ob das wird toll
sie hat freiwillig die kriege angezogen
sie ist übergewechselt in das lager zu
karl lauterbach und das ist mutig
verschwand lassen sie mich das sagen es
ist mutig
natürlich eine fliege lesen klartext
mutig nein das ist völlig und sie nicht
gerade sagen wir haben doch alle
ähnliches ziel und insofern sollte am
selben ende vom strick ziehen mit den
anderen vom strick ist auch ein schönes
welchem sprang am stricken sie haben bei
der spd nicht regulieren das tut weh
[Musik]
für weitere videos klickt unten und
abonniert auch unseren channel alles im
kasten
ok wo geht's denn hier raus
scheiße